le président mes chers collègues avec
jean sol permettez nous d'avoir une
pensée pour les habitants de notre
département et les services de secours
notre département franc est frappé par
la tempête gloria ma question s'adresse
au secrétaire d'état aux transports
monsieur secrétaire d'état ma question a
pour but de s'inquiéter des retards du
développement qualitatif et quantitatif
de nos infrastructures de transport elle
porte sur le devenir du réseau routier
national
le 15 mai dernier dit 2018 vous
confirmiez que 50% des chaussées étaient
à renouveler est un pont sur dix étaient
en mauvais état des experts ont chiffré
le montant des investissements à 1
milliard d'euros supplémentaires par an
dans les deux derniers budget de l'état
le compte n'y est pas plus inquiétant
encore pour la première fois les
mobilités ne figure pas dans les
objectifs du nouveau contrat de plantes
2021 et 2027
pourtant le réseau routier reste un
enjeu stratégique pour le désenclavement
et l'économie de nos départements dans
cette négociation du contrat de plan
pouvez vous nous confirmer que les
crédits routiers n'y figureront plus
parallèlement vous entamer la
concertation sur le projet de loi 3d le
transfert du réseau routier national aux
collectivités territoriales fera t-il
l'objet de ce projet de loi
et quel crédit qui affecterait vous